[Applause]  come on quickly to James James's waiting  for help he's won on four right now  [Applause]  PJ gets it out to Russell way with  Russell Westbrook you better rocket  ransom from another universe you guys  had to go to Minnesota the next night  Houston the to Minnesota at least they  gained in our last night  [Music]  Gardens got him mesmerized  little garden penises did that to snatch  back hardens limit his minutes in his  career he's got that lovely body  he knows how to play this game art with  a three before 15 yeah there boy 15 good  last way was like no rivers and levers  garden again about all the players that  have played in the NBA tracks only 10%  of those players have a career high  [Music]  [Music]